ja und in erfurt begrüße ich jetzt den
parteivorsitzenden
naja afd alexander gauland gute namen
nach erfurt
guten abend herr gauck ihre partei hat
das ergebnis von 2014 mehr als
verdoppelt worauf führen sie dieses
ergebnis zurück auf unsere themen und
einen hervorragenden wahlkampf den die
thüringer parteifreunde oder berkel
gemacht haben und aber es sind natürlich
die themen es gibt eben viele menschen
gott sei dank die diese veränderung des
landes die ich gerade von frau berg
gehört habe nicht wollen
jetzt ist ja der spitzenkandidat ihrer
partei blöcke auch in der afg selbst
höchst umstritten es gab sogar mal ein
parteiausschlussverfahren gegen wir an
heute sind sie denn froh darüber dass da
ein politiker triumphiert er die partei
so weit nach rechts rückt also der hecke
rückt die partei nicht nach rechts
stärke ist die mitte der partei und er
gehört zur partei und er war ein sehr
erfolgreicher spitzenkandidat ist ein
sehr erfolgreicher spitzenkandidatin
sogar habe ich überhaupt keine einwände
gegen den wahlkampf der thüringischen
parteifreunde wenn sie jetzt selber
sagen die anhänger ist die mitte der
partei verschließen sie da nicht von
sich aus alle türen zu den anderen
parteien zur cdu zum beispiel der sie ja
immer wieder avancen machen und sagen
wir sollten zusammenarbeiten
also ich sage nicht wir wollten
zusammenarbeiten ich sage nur die cdu
muss sich überlegen ob sie auf dauer
links grün regieren will oder ob sie
eine bürgerliche mehrheit herstellen
will wenn sie das will muss sie in der
tat auf uns zugehen aber das wird
bestimmt nicht dazu führen dass wir
bürger für die cdu ab
da alle vorwürfe gegen ihn natürlich
falsch sind das wissen sie auch und dass
diese vorwürfe oder vorhaltungen er sei
rechtsradikal völliger unsinn ist aber
die cdu muss wahrscheinlich noch mehr
lernen sie hat offensichtlich schon
einmal gelernt aus dem wahlergebnis sie
wird aber noch mehr lernen müssen und
vor allen dingen müssen die funktionäre
lernen und die basis muss aufstehen und
den funktionären in der cdu deutlich
sagen dass das so nicht geht man könnte
eine bürgerliche mehrheit organisieren
aber da müsste in der tat die
funktionärsschicht die merkel geprägt
ist ein klicken und ich fürchte das
geschieht noch nicht also gegen den
begriff bürgerliche koalition wird sich
die cdu natürlich wären damit sie
gemeint sind die vorwürfe gegen thun
hatte die fall ja nicht vom himmel ich
darf mal ein paar argumente anführen
erstes mal
der verfassungsschutz hat den flügeln
und da steht ja ganz von der birke als
verdachtsfall eingestuft böcke spricht
von einer mahnmal der schande wenn er
über das holocaust-mahnmal spricht und
benützer formulierungen wie folgt tot
bist durch bevölkerungsaustausch und das
ist wirklich die mitte ihrer partei
also dass der verfassungsschutz ist für
mich überhaupt kein maßstab den er ist
natürlich das instrument der
herrschenden
es ist ganz klar dass die anderen
parteien mit dem verfassungsschutz ihre
konkurrenz loswerden wollen und jetzt
sagen sie mir bitte was an den begriff
mahnmal der schande falsch ist das nicht
unsere schande gewesen hat er nicht
völlig zu recht formuliert von daher
sehe ich überhaupt keine problematik in
dem was sie gerade vorgetragen haben
also ich will jetzt nicht mit ihnen in
die nun wirklich endlosen diskussionen
über diesen begriff man lade der schande
eintreten sondern mit ihnen
sie treten nicht ein weil immer wieder
dasselbe behauptet wird er hat es ja
auch ganz klar gesagt und er hat es
immer wieder betont es sei das mahnmal
unserer schande
und warum darf man heute etwas nicht
sagen was rudolf augstein im spiegel
geschrieben hat und zwar mit sehr viel
na sagen wir mal vorsichtig zum teil
antisemitischen anschuldigungen die in
seinem berühmten artikel als das mahnmal
noch nicht gebaut war vorgekommen sind
ein höcker wird einsatz im grunde
genommen ja dauernd vorgehalten die
ihnen andere siehe auch stein gebraucht
haben und das kann ich überhaupt nicht
verstehen deshalb mit rechtsradikalen
nichts zu tun
gut dann muss ich das einfach nochmal
nachschieben das wird heute immer wieder
vorgeworfen weil eben die meisten bürger
die meisten kommentatoren es so
verstehen dass heute sagt es ist eine
schande dass wir dieses mahnmal nach
berlin setzen lassen sie uns trotzdem
jetzt machen sie ganz verstehen was sie
wollen es ist einfach falsch es ist
schon begrifflich falsch er hat vom
mahnmal der schande gesprochen von
mahnmal unserer schande eine andere
schande kann er nicht gemeint haben
also ist das was er gesagt hat richtig
und ich weiß nicht warum kommentatoren
da immer daran herum deuteln also ich
gehe jetzt mal davon aus dass wir die
argumente über das mahnmal das an der
ausgetauscht haben und möchte gerne
eingehen auf die situation in thüringen
wir haben jetzt keine mehrheit für rot
rot grün
wir haben auch keine mehrheit für eine
mögliche simbabwe regierung des
cdu-spitzenkandidaten mohring wie wird
ihre partei mit dieser situation umgehen
das ist nicht zuerst unsere partei die
amet umgehen muss wenn herr mohring eine
andere koalition will wenn er den
versuch machen will
eine echte koalition der mitte zu bauen
hat er ja die chance er kann auf die afg
zu gehen er kann auf die fdp zugehen
er hat alle möglichkeiten aber da muss
er sich halt von dieser märkischen
haltung trennen
dass die afg sozusagen irgendetwas
jenseits des demokratischen spektrums
ist es schon jung
es haben uns ein viertel der thüringer
gewählt es ist wohl völlig falsch
anzunehmen dass das alles irgendwelche
rechtsradikalen sind nein wir sind
stehen mitten in der demokratischen
gesellschaft und die cdu muss damit
umgehen sonst wird sie den charakter der
volkspartei verlieren und wir werden die
konservative bürgerliche volkspartei auf
die in diesem weg sind wir schon es ist
jetzt an der fr der cdu deutlich zu
sagen was sie will und eine deutliche
köpfe einzuschlagen
soweit der parteivorsitzende der afg aus
erfurt alexander gauland herzlichen dank